je crois que on a assisté hier on va
essayer aujourd'hui à une belle synthèse
de pearl de comptoir donc je suggère à
celles et ceux qui aiment bien les
bonnes petites blagues d'imprimer le
discours petit général parce que à en
croire la situation qui est dépeint par
bernard cazeneuve
on a l'impression que tout va bien et on
se demande pourquoi françois hollande
n'a pas été candidat dans ces conditions
là à l'écouter l'économie l'emploi
les résultats sont là je crois que
j'incite a beaucoup plus d'humilité
parce que d'ailleurs en cinq mois je ne
pense pas qu'il puisse réaliser ce
qu'ils n'ont pas fait en cinq ans alors
bernard cazeneuve a attaqué frontalement
france fiant sur son programme de santé
sur la réduction du nombre de
fonctionnaires
qu'est ce que vous lui répondez 5
bernard cazeneuve a dit devant les
députés socialistes hier je veux
combattre la droite
moi je les incite tout simplement à
combattre encore une fois le chômage à
combattre le déclin économique
je penserai plus utile et surtout ça
fait un peu moins double langage parce
que il fait des grandes phrases pour
appeler à l'unité nationale
mais donc quand on veut l'unité
nationale il s'agit pas de s'en prendre
et bien aux leaders de l'opposition qui
par ailleurs est candidat à l'élection
présidentielle